my honor to be here to stand
on the shoulders of those who came
before
to speak tonight as your vice president
in many ways this moment embodies our
character
as a nation it demonstrates who we are
even in dark times we not only dream
we do we not only see what has been
we see what can be we shoot for the moon
and then we plant our flag on it
we are bold fearless and
ambitious we are undaunted
in our belief that we shall overcome
that we will rise up
this is american aspiration
in the middle of the civil war abraham
lincoln saw a better future
and built it with land grant colleges
and the transcontinental railroad in the
middle
of the civil rights movement dr king
fought for racial justice and economic
justice
american aspiration is what drove the
women of this nation
throughout history to demand equal
rights
and the authors of the bill of rights to
claim
freedoms that had rarely been written
down before
a great experiment takes great
determination the will to do the work
and then the wisdom to keep refining
keep tinkering keep perfecting
the same determination is being realized
in america today i see it
in the scientists who are transforming
the future i see it and the
parents who are nurturing generations to
come in the innovators and the educators
in everyone everywhere who is building a
better life
for themselves their families and their
communities
this too is american aspiration
this is what president joe biden has
called upon
us to summon now the courage
to see beyond crisis to do what is hard
to do what is good to unite
to believe in ourselves believe
in our country believe in what we can do
together thank you
and may god bless america